- [Voiceover] So I have three different
relationships here between X and Y.
And what I wanna think about
which of these, if any, are
proportional relationships.
And then I wanna graph them to see
if we can see anything visually
that makes them obviously proportional.
And just as a reminder,
a proportional relationship is one
where the ratio between the two variables,
and let's say we took the
ratio between Y and X,
you could also go the other way around,
the ratio between X and Y.
But the ratio between
Y and X is always going
to be some number, some constant number.
Or you could rewrite it another way,
If you were to multiply both sides
of this equation times X,
you could say in a
proportional relationship,
Y is always going to be equal
to some constant times X.
So with that out of the way,
let's look at these three relationships.
So this one over here,
let me draw another column here.
Another column.
This is, let me call
this the Y over X column.
I'm just gonna keep figuring
out what this ratio is
for each of these pairs.
So for this first pair,
when X is one, Y is one half,
so this ratio is one half over one.
Well one half over one is just
the same thing as one half.
When X is four, Y is two,
this ratio is gonna be
two over four, which is
the same thing as one half.
When X is negative two
and Y is negative one,
this ratio is negative
one over negative two,
which is the same thing as one half.
So for at least these three points
that we've sampled from this relationship,
it looks like the ratio between
Y and X is always one half.
In this case K would be one half,
we could write Y over X is
always equal to one half.
Or at least for these three
points that we've sampled,
and we'll say, well, maybe
it's always the case,
for this relationship between X and Y,
or if you wanted to write it another way,
you could write that Y
is equal to one half X.
Now let's graph this thing.
Well, when X is one, Y is one half.
When X is four, Y is two.
When X is negative two, Y is negative one.
I didn't put the marker for negative one,
it would be right about there.
And so if we say these three points
are sampled on the entire relationship,
and the entire relationship
is Y is equal to one half X,
well the line that represents,
or the set of all points
that would represent
the possible X-Y pairs,
it would be a line.
It would be a line that
goes through the origin.
Because look, if X is
zero, one half times zero
is going to be equal to Y.
And so let's think about some
of the key characteristics.
One, it is a line.
This is a line here.
It is a linear relationship.
And it also goes through the origin.
And it makes sense that
it goes through an origin.
Because in a proportional relationship,
actually when you look over here,
zero over zero, that's indeterminate form,
and then that gets a little bit strange,
but when you look at this right over here,
well if X is zero and you
multiply it by some constant,
Y is going to need to be zero as well.
So for any proportional relationship,
if you're including when X equals zero,
then Y would need to be
equal to zero as well.
And so if you were to plot its graph,
it would be a line that
goes through the origin.
It would be a line that
And so this is a proportional relationship
and its graph is represented by a line
that goes through the origin.
Now let's look at this one over here,
this one in blue.
So let's think about
whether it is proportional.
And we could do the same test,
by calculating the ratio between Y and X.
Y and X.
So it's going to be, let's see,
for this first one it's
going to be three over one,
which is just three.
Then it's gonna be five over two.
Five over two,
well five over two is not
the same thing as three.
So already we know that
this is not proportional.
Not proportional.
We don't even have to look
at this third point right over here,
where if we took the
ratio between Y and X,
it's negative one over negative one,
which would just be one.
Let's see, let's graph this just for fun,
to see what it looks like.
When X is one, Y is three.
When X is two, Y is five.
X is two, Y is five.
And when X is negative
one, Y is negative one.
When X is negative one, Y is negative one.
And I forgot to put the
hash mark right there,
it was right around there.
And so if we said, okay,
let's just give the benefit of the doubt
that maybe these are
three points from a line,
because it looks like I can actually
connect them with a line.
Then the line would look
something like this.
The line would look something like this.
So notice, this is linear.
This is a line right over here.
But it does not go through the origin.
So if you're just looking
at a relationship visually,
linear is good, but it needs to go through
the origin as well for it to
be proportional relationship.
And you see that right here.
This is a linear relationship,
or at least these three
pairs could be sampled
from a linear relationship,
but the graph does not
go through the origin.
And we see here, when
we look at the ratio,
that it was indeed not proportional.
So this is not proportional.
Now let's look at this one over here.
Let's look at what we have here.
So I'll look at the ratios.
Y over X.
So for this first pair, one over one,
then we have four over two,
well we immediately see that
we are not proportional.
And then nine over
three, it would be three.
So clearly this is not
a constant number here.
We don't always have the same value here,
and so this is also not proportional.
Not proportional.
But let's graph it just for fun.
When X is one, Y is one.
When X is two, Y is four.
This actually looks like
the graph of Y is equal to X squared.
When X is three, Y is nine.
At least these three points
are consistent with it.
So one, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
So it's gonna look something...
And so, if this really is,
if these points are sampled
from Y equals X squared,
then when X is zero, Y would be zero.
So this one actually would
go through the origin,
but notice, it's not a line.
It's not a linear relationship.
This right over here is the
graph of Y equals X squared.
So this one also is not proportional.
So once again, these three points
could be sampled from Y equals one half X,
these three points could be sampled from,
let's see, Y is equal to, let's see,
it looks like a line when...
this looks like it could be Y = 2x + 1.
So it's a linear relationship,
but it does not go through the origin,
so it's not proportional.
And these three points look
like they could be sampled
from Y equals X squared,
which goes through the origin.
When X is zero, Y is zero,
but it's not a linear relationship.
Any way you look at it,
if you look at it visually,
it has to be a line that
goes through the origin,
or if you look at a table of
values, look at the ratios,
and the ratios always
have to be the same value.
And that was only the case
with this magenta one,
right over here.